In recent decades, it has been normal to consider
the tenant of the White House, the President
of the United States, as the most powerful
person in the world.
However, dear viewer, things may be changing...
or may have already changed.
Have you heard about the Chinese President?
Yes, of course you have, we mentioned him
several times here on VisualPolitik.
See, Donald Trump himself, in statements collected
by the Washington Post, described the Chinese
president, Xi Jinping, as the most powerful
leader that China has had in the last century...
which is as good as saying that Xi Jinping
is the most powerful Chinese leader of all
time.
So much so that more and more analysts are
wondering if he isn’t, in fact, the most
powerful political leader in the world.
Yes, it’s true.
Both China's economy, as well as its army,
are still on a second level if we compare
it to the United States... but, while Trump
seems to be consistently losing his influence
over the world and, indeed, his own country,
the situation is quite the opposite for Xi
Jinping.
Wait, wait, wait...
Trump is losing influence in the US?…
How could this be if Donald wants to be everyone's
friend… have you seen his sweet tweets recently?
Why would Kim Jong-un insult me by calling
me "old," when I would NEVER call him "short
and fat?"
Oh well, I try so hard to be his friend - and
maybe someday that will happen!
Yes... it's definitely no surprise that the
United States is losing its influence over
the world...
In very few months, Trump has gone from nuclear
war... to schoolyard fights.
Anyway, back to the serious stuff.
The fact is that although Xi Jinping isn’t
the President of the world's leading power,
he does control China’s leadership tightly,
a country which is one of the most important
economic engines on the planet.
And of course, for Beijing, Trump has been
something like… the Lottery Jackpot.
Protectionism, nationalism, and Donald Trump’s
mistakes have allowed Xi Jinping, the President
of China (the world's largest dictatorship)
to present his candidacy as a kind of global
political leader.
In January 2017, at the Davos Forum, Xi Jinping
promised that China would become nothing less
than the champion of globalization, free trade,
and even the fight against climate change.
Thus, Beijing aspires to put its grasp on
the terrain that Washington has been losing
in international politics.
He only forgot to mention freedom.. and you
know those sort of things…
But what happened in the last Chinese Communist
Party Congress?
How much power does Xi Jinping have?
What does he want?
Well, we’ll discuss this, but first let’s
take a look at China today.
THE NEW CHINA
Do you think that China is still that country
where people live under deplorable conditions,
breaking their backs for miserable wages?
Well...
I'm sorry, but you're quite wrong.
2018 will be the 40th anniversary of China's
reform and open policy.
And this country has changed a lot in that
time…
China is no longer a low-income country, but
a middle-income country.
In fact, taking price differences into account,
it’d have purchasing power parity of about
$16,000, bigger than both Colombia and Brazil.
Also, its economy has changed, and nowadays
services are the most important activity.
For example in electronic commerce, a sector
in which this country is beating Europe and
even the United States, China represents no
less than 40% of all global transactions.
The same can be said of mobile payments, which
are so popular in this country, that its market
reached 5.5 trillion dollars in 2016.
50 times more than the United States.
Not bad, right?
Their growth has been so large, that just
in the last 6 years, China’s private consumption
has grown by 2.5 trillion dollars, an amount
that equals India’s entire GDP.
Therefore, when visiting one of these big
Chinese cities, it isn’t odd to find a landscape
full of skyscrapers, billionaires and high-speed
trains.
But, wait a second… because China’s poverty
continues and, in general, there is a rather
large difference between the country’s cities
and rural areas, which remain poor... very
poor.
So much so that 43 million people, almost
the entire population of Spain, still live
in extreme poverty, earning less than $1 a
day.
And not only that, almost 40% of Chinese people
still live at a fairly low economic level,
although the situation is much better than
a few decades ago.
This is all true, but as I said before, things
are changing very quickly, and we can no longer
think of China as we did 20, 10 or even just
5 years ago.
By the way, talking about poverty...
here’s a interesting fact, do you know how
the Chinese government fights against poverty?
Well, one of its main strategies is creating
new businesses and cooperatives in the poorest
communities.
To this end, the government has granted almost
400 billion dollars in small loans to help
launch several companies.
And, they not only focus on a money, but also
on culture.
“The evening news is filled with tales of
rejuvenated communities, and villagers-turned-entrepreneurs
heaping praise on Mr. Xi and the government
for providing loans and new apartments.”
Javier C. Hernández, China correspondent
for The New York Times.
Yes, I know...
Xi Jinping and practically every country leader
talk a lot about "Chinese-style socialism"...
The truth is, this is just a reference to
a kind of capitalist model locked within a
dictatorship.
China isn’t an ideological dictatorship...
nor a socialist or communist one... it’s
simply a dictatorship.
Having said this... let’s talk about Xi
Jinping, the person leading this new China,
with almost complete power.
XI JINPING, THE LEADER
Born in 1953, we could say that Xi Jinping
is a pretty interesting guy.
On the one hand, he’s probably the Chinese
leader who’s had the most contact with the
West.
His daughter studied at Harvard, his sister
lives in Canada, and he has visited the United
States several times.
In fact, in 2012 when he visited the United
States as vice president of China, he made
a somewhat peculiar stop: he went to Iowa.
“Iowa, why Iowa?”
Obama wondered…
Well, the fact is that in 1985 when Xi Jinping
was a young party county secretary in China,
he traveled to Iowa to investigate agriculture-related
issues.
So in 2012, he went to see the family he’d
stayed with at the time and brought them presents.
Cool story, right?
In addition, President Xi’s ‘Yankee’
side doesn’t end there, he’s also known
to love Hollywood movies.
But there’s also another side to this.
Since he became China’s highest authority
5 years ago, his government has been characterized
for having the most censorship and repression
for a very long time.
We only need to take a look at the latest
cybersecurity law, which seeks to control
even more Internet in China by restricting
anonymity.
Indeed this is to such an extent that all
social network accounts have to be backed
by an identified citizen.
Further, it has been decades since China saw
such a strong a leader.
We could say that propaganda has worked gradually.
But… that’s not really surprising, is
it?
The
fact is that in these 5 years, Xi Jinping
has made several changes in China...
starting with the army reform and their very
active foreign policy.
We saw it here, at VisualPolitik, how Xi Jinping
has diverted national resources towards foreign
policy.
A good example is the New Silk Road macro-project,
which aims to invest hundreds of billions
of dollars in several countries.
But generally, their greatest commitment has
definitely been the fight against corruption.
And this is very important...
Since Xi Jinping came to power, over one and
a half million members of the Communist Party
have been sanctioned and nearly 300,000 have
been prosecuted, including 43 members of the
Central Committee.
And there’s more...
Within the framework of this fight against
corruption, 13,000 army officers have been
dismissed and more than 50 generals imprisoned.
Of course...
not everyone sees this battle as something
clean and honest:
“It’s a selective anti-corruption campaign.
Its nature is the selective protection of
corruption.
When you purge some corrupt officials, you
are protecting the others.
You protect the corrupt system, and you protect
corrupt people who support you.”
Bao Tong, chinese activist.
Yes, Xi Jinping has mostly "relieved" his
political rivals, coincidence?!
Of course, it’s very clear that Xi Jinping
has gained a lot of power in these five years.
This was certainly observed in the last Chinese
Communist Party Congress, the most important
political event in the country, which is held
every five years.
THE 19TH CONGRESS
This nineteenth Chinese Communist Party Congress,
held between October 18-24, 2017, was quite
particular, especially because it may have
been the most austere Congress that the Chinese
Communist Party has celebrated in many, many
years.
On this occasion some amenities were removed,
want some examples?
Well, among other things – and this is no
joke – the fancy buffet was abolished, as
was hairdressing, facials and tailoring services,
which used to be offered for free to all participants
and which had almost become a tradition.
But above all, this was the Congress at which
Xi Jinping’s adoration reached its highest
point, something that, as you can imagine
in China, means being put almost on a Mao-like
level.
“Five years ago I said he would be China’s
most powerful leader since Deng Xiaoping.
I was wrong.
He is now China’s most powerful leader since
Mao Zedong,” Kevin Rudd, Australia’s former
Prime Minister.
See, this Congress lead to the decision that
the so-called "Xi Jinping thought" should
be included in the Communist Party Constitution.
This may seem a bit strange, but it actually
means that Xi Jinping is no longer just another
leader, he is THE leader, the leader whose
words form the party's own ideology.
“It means Xi is effectively unassailable
… If you challenge Xi, you are challenging
the party – and you never want to be against
the party.”
Bill Bishop, publisher of the Sinocism newsletter.
So far, only Mao Zedong had received such
an honor in life.
But that's not all.
Currently a president’s mandate is limited
to 10 years, which means that this would be
Xi Jinping’s last term… but… wait a
minute… because no successor was considered
during the congress, which leads us to believe
that Xi Jinping may be aspiring to, at least,
a third mandate.
“Chinese universities scramble to open centers
to study President Xi Jinping Thought”.
But anyway, beyond the Chinese leader, this
Congress helped define 3 major priorities
for the Chinese government for the upcoming
years:
First - the Economy - fighting poverty and
opening up more to the world;
Second - Launch an even stronger foreign policy
Third - Start worrying about the Environment.
And well, even though I said 3 priorities,
there is a fourth, and very clear one: consolidate
the Communist Party’s power.
Because, we know two things for sure:
On the one hand, Xi Jinping and the Chinese
Communist Party will stay for a long time.
And on the other, China will reclaim its role
as a superpower.
So let’s get used to taking Beijing into
account...
Now it's your turn.
Who do you think will leave power first, XI
Jinping or Vladimir Putin?!
Leave your answer in the comments as well
as in the survey.
I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did and don’t forget to
subscribe to our channel for brand new videos
every Monday and Thursday.
Also, don’t forget to check out our friends
at the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine!
And as always, thanks for watching!